so last time Charlie was here he talked
about his first time doing comedies did
you remember your first time doing
comedy yeah it was an open mic I brought
20 friends did well performed the next
week brought no friends and bombed so I
distinctly remember that and I stayed in
medicine for 10 more years so
it broke me
I did not do very well so
so are just live performance and to do
that and you're just there with the mic
nothing else yeah when you when you when
you do well you feel like a million
bucks and when you bomb you you're broke
emotionally emotionally and financially
try doing that in Rhode Island okay okay
Doctor boy make me laugh yeah he's good
but he's no Kevin Costner yeah he's like
he's
he's OCTA funny which isn't funny at all
so what you're you know I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]